hi for those of you who haven't seen any
of my videos before my name is Simon and
I'm currently studying for a PhD in
climate physics at the University of
Exeter
now before I came to university and I
made physics my thing at school my thing
was public speaking I did a lot of
competitive debating and after-dinner
speaking and I won some awards for both
I thought that this was a skill set
which a lot of people don't have and
often they want to have so I thought
that I try and do almost like a video
textbook on the subject and try and get
my thoughts down in some form or other
I've done a video like this before if
you haven't seen that that's my how to
study effectively video a link to that
will be in the description what I've
done is split the skill of public
speaking down to three P's preparation
performance and practice and we're going
to go through each one of those in turn
now
so the first P is preparation and before
you do anything before we even think
about getting on a stage before you even
write the script you have to ask
yourself some questions where are you
speaking to whom you speaking why are
you speaking and how long are you
expected to speak for may your answers
to those questions are going to
determine everything that happens
subsequently so I think carefully about
them I'm trying to make this video as
general as possible but with a slight
emphasis on speaking to persuade or
inform like in competitive debating so
if you're doing this then there are some
additional questions you have to
consider what are you talking about and
what does your audience already know
about where you're going to be talking
about perhaps more importantly what is
your audience's perception of what
you're going to be talking about and
then ultimately what do you want your
audience to walk away from your speech
knowing or thinking that they didn't
before the next step once you've
considered those questions is to
construct your script and a script can
vary widely in format depending on what
you're doing if you're giving a eulogy
or if you're speaking off the dinner
it's going to be very very different
from if you're speaking at a competitive
debate if you are speaking to persuade
or to inform then there's a very general
format which you can follow first have
an introduction to your speech then make
the main points of your speech ideally
three they'll come back to that and then
a conclusion at the end or more simply
tell people you're going to tell them
tell them and then tell them what you've
told them aiming for three main points
ideally in a short speech of say five
minutes is ideal because that's a good
amount of information to
and also a base of all of triplets
generally if you use three items in a
speech that could be three points three
nouns or three adjectives one after the
other then it makes for a nice sentence
to listen to you like I just did that
when you make your points don't just
state something don't just say a point
it's important to say your point and
then back it up with some evidence so
for example I might say that the
University of Exeter cares about its
students and I might back that up by
saying for example in the past couple of
years they've spent 318 million pounds
on new facilities for students then I
could follow that up with second part of
the argument for example and this is
netting them more and more of the best
candidates in the country elevating them
to seventh in The Times UK universities
table now these two points of using
triplets and using a point pull up by
evidence you might be familiar with from
essay writing now a lot of the
techniques do carry over from prose or
essay writing into script writing but be
wary I'd recommend that you read out
your script as you write it because
something can look fantastic on the page
but just a little bit odd or stilted
when you say it out loud to find a
points to consider in preparation
firstly think about how much human it
would be appropriate for the speech
which are giving I personally like to
use quite a bit of humor I spread it
pretty evenly from any speech which I
give if it's a propria it gives people
something to kind of fall back on it
especially if it's a heavy topic it's
quite nice just have some light relief
and it also drags people back in who
stopped listening secondly try to
incorporate some callbacks or call
forwards into your script that's when
you make reference to something which
you're going to say or something which
you have said in the past or better yet
something which has happened at the
event you are speaking at say something
someone else has mentioned that that's
more appropriate in the next section
performance now my personal approach to
public speaking is that it is a
performance like any other like acting
or music or dance in those performances
you'll not true yourself when you're on
stage especially in acting you adopt a
stage persona which can be very
dissimilar from yourself in public
speaking I think the key is to make a
stage persona which is always the same
as you but to be that little bit more
persuasive than
a bit more convincing articulate and the
point of the mask isn't so much for
people who are listening to what you're
saying it's more for yourself it's more
to convince yourself that it's not
actually you onstage you're not
vulnerable it's this persona which
you've constructed now it's very easy
when doing this to come off as sleazy or
cliched or fake and that's something
which you should take great pains to
avoid and it's most easily done by being
genuine by just being yourself so I'm
gonna break down the performance aspect
to this video into three subsections
your physical performance your vocal
performance and your delivery of the
script physically firstly consider what
you are wearing and how you look people
judge on appearence is far more than
that ever willing to admit in my opinion
and they're more likely to believe what
a well-dressed person has to say poorly
dressed person so think about the attire
for the event you're speaking up and do
it well or maybe even a step it up a
notch
look smart look clean and look natural
in what you're wearing secondly stand up
never speak sitting down unless you
absolutely have to standing up straight
allows you for better breath control but
a voice projection and it makes you look
better so stand tall with good posture
thirdly consider how you move your body
a very common problem is to use your
hands too much and articulate every
single point but using our hands sparing
you to emphasize key points is exactly
what you should be doing but waving
around all the time is overkill so if
you're speaking at a lectern I'd
recommend that you make your default
hand position to put your hands on the
lectern that way you're not quite so
tempted to wave them around also if you
are speaking to a large crowd of people
make sure that you turn your head make
sure that you look at everybody in the
audience always think like you're a fan
in a room so that nobody is in a large
room feels left out maybe dwell on some
places for a little bit longer than
others but then always keep moving
overhead so nobody feels left out also
if you're feeling nervous then a tip
which might help you plant your feet
thoroughly on the ground so make contact
with your big toe your little toe and
your heel then stand up straight keep
your core tight and you should feel like
a mountain
though do move your feet from time to
time you don't really want to stand sort
of in one spot for the entire time next
your vocal performance first of all it
is incredibly important to vary the
pitch speed tone and volume of your
speech depending on what you're talking
about
you might slow down and get softer and
quieter if you're making no emotional
point or you might speed up and get
slightly harsh mean tone and then maybe
it's been really quite quickly so people
have a full sense of security before you
slow down and you deliver a really hard
point to home doing this makes you a lot
more engaging and interesting to listen
to and it adds an extra layer of
structure to each of your sentences
particularly if you vary your pitch
secondly silence is an incredibly
powerful tool when used sparingly a
well-timed pause can add and persist
draw people in and lead to a heightened
sense of anticipation so think carefully
about where you're going to put your
pauses thirdly and this might sound a
little bit odd but be in control of your
mouth good pronunciation and
articulation are very important that
doesn't mean you have to speak the
Queen's English and correctly enunciate
at the R and T you just have to be
understandable it should never be a
struggle to understand what you're
trying to say so if you're feeling
nervous then slow down a little bit some
people tend to speak very quickly when
they get nervous so slow down slightly
think about your articulation and make
sure that people can clearly understand
what you're trying to say lastly
performance delivering your script and
the first point to make is do not read
from your script while you are speaking
in fact don't take a full copy of your
script to your speech because nobody
wants to see this
I'd recommend cue cards if you're aloud
made even if you don't use them they can
be comforting and on them put the key
points of your speech key statistics
maybe and if you're giving a PowerPoint
maybe one card per slide so awful lot
better than doing that secondly and on a
related point do not just recite your
speech from memory there are very few
things less convincing
and somebody just rattling off in a dull
monotone some pre-plan especially
political script in my opinion the most
convincing delivery is one which makes
it seem as if the presenter is just
making it up on the spot but getting
everything right and being convincing
what I'm doing right now I actually
wrote this grit worth the word quite a
few days ago but I'm making you think
that I'm delivering it off-the-cuff
right now and it makes an author not
convincing in if I just read it out in a
dull monotone lastly and something which
I've already mentioned before try to
incorporate things which have happened
at the event which are speaking out so
for example if you're speaking at an
event where there are lots of people
giving speeches then if the speaker for
you is called Mark he might open your
speech by saying thank you very much
mark
for a lovely speech nice easier to
follow then you can put that in your
script very generally you might put in
little note that says insert reference
to previous speaker here or insert
reference to this particular event in
here so you can do that in advance but
more often than not it's actually more
convincing to genuinely make that up on
the night or even on the fly or whilst
you're speaking doing this effectively
can make the difference between a good
speaker and a great one now last P
practice so there's a subject which I've
only touched on once in this video up to
this point arguably is the subject which
affects the most people when it comes to
public speaking and that's the sensation
of being nervous when speaking to a
large number of people and it's entirely
understandable we're not really
hardwired to do it at any point in our
lives but when it does come to that
moment people working or not they
stammer of what they're gonna say they
might speak too quickly or they might
just forget what they're gonna say now
the only way to really gain confidence
in speaking to a large number of people
is to speak to a large number of people
and do it a lot unfortunately hence why
the third P is practice but practice
helps you in a slightly different form
of confidence so once you've written you
a script and you know how you're going
to deliver it then stand in front of the
mirror with your script and deliver it
to yourself pretend you're on the
audience and maybe do that another time
and just know sort of your mannerisms
and trying to let the script seep into
your mind
now put the script to one side with no
age try and do the same thing and see
how far you get now
when you get to a point where you just
can't continue don't know what you're
gonna say look at script read it again
then put it to one side do the same
thing deliver the speech and see how far
you can get and then if you get to the
end that's fantastic but if you don't
because you're probably not look at the
speech again
and keep doing that until you can get to
the end of your speech without having to
use any form of aid now you are more
likely than not going to deliver the
speech with some kind of aids whether
that be a cue cards or something else so
do the same thing again but have those
cue cards or whatever it may be with you
and deliver the speech to the minute
and what you should find is that when
you do have a slight moment you can't
know where it is you have the cue cards
to remind you what that statistic is
going to be the point of doing all this
is to give you confidence in your
materials so that you know what you're
gonna say even if you don't necessarily
have confidence in your performance of
actually getting up on stage and sing
that's unfortunately the answer vector
confidence which you do just get from
practice but you can at least have
confidence and know exactly what you're
gonna say having done public speaking
for so many years now I don't really get
nervous in this way anymore many times
which I do when I worry about how the
audience's perception of me is going to
be changed by what I have to say this
happened recently when I was presenting
my research at a department Talk so the
best advice which I can give to you if
you are struggling with this confidence
in your performance it's to remember
that it is just that it's a performance
it's not really you that's delivering
these lines or going through the motions
it's your stage persona because
ultimately what you're doing is you're
going up on the stage you're delivering
your lines you're going through the
motions and you're trying to communicate
something that's ultimately what any
performance is just try to do as that
so to recap any public speaking
performance requires thought in
preparation performance and practice
carefully consider what you're going to
say then in performance think about your
physicality your voice and how you
deliver the script and most importantly
of all practice those things and maybe
look back through this video and see how
I use those techniques hopefully
effectively I hope that you found this
video useful if you did enjoy it then
please do feel free to like it
you don't have to it's a free world and
you can leave a comment down below
saying what you liked or maybe you
didn't like about it if you liked the
look of my face then maybe you can check
out the rest of my youtube channel I try
not load videos as often as I can
they because I'm a PhD student that's
not as often as I or my subscribers
would really like thank you very much
for watching